vous allez chercher et trouver on va
dire un bateau environ 20 30 cm qui qui
vous plaît alesis chercher le se
reconnecter à la forie à son
environnement pour fêter la saint
valentin c'est l'une des promesses de
cet établissement situé sur la commune
de bonnel à deux pas de la forêt de
rambouillet aujourd'hui isabelle teste
son coin avant de recevoir les couples
pour la fête des amoureux
objectif le bien-être on est souvent
déconnecté par notre travail par le fait
d'habiter au 20ème étage le fait d'être
en ville on est déconnecté de la nature
et c'est vrai que pour être bien pour
gérer son stress
on peut aller dans la nature et profiter
notamment des arbres avec les terpènes
et puis ton side et tous les bienfaits
qu'ils ont naturellement pendant le
cours d'une heure et demie plusieurs
ateliers sont proposés pour éveiller les
sens avec ces différents éléments
ça va être de mettre en avant la mouche
des arbres ou même par terre donc ça
peut être en fait faire ressortir comme
ça et là on voit l'arbre mais on voit
aussi la taquine ion le moment fort de
la session la reconnexion osa dans l'est
touchant pendant plusieurs minutes pour
ressentir la vie la sève qui passe
quelque part c'est aussi un moment
d'introspection
parce qu'on peut tout à fait confier une
joie une peine à voir une question et
c'est un moment d'ouverture esprits à la
fin de la session première réaction
c'est une expérience vraiment inédite et
ressourçante je pense en rapport avec le
monde de demain vers la nature c'est pas
du tout conventionnelle c'est très
naturel très très différent de
de ce qui peut être très connu voilà
donc c'est une expérience qui est très
sympa à faire si vous êtes moins
terre-à-terre l'établissement compte
également 73 champ mais d'autres
activités dont les ateliers yoga pour
profiter de ce week-end de
saint-valentin il faudra débourser 420
euros pour une chambre double